[Music]
hello
it is time for dear drew thank you so
much for taking the time
this summer to send us your beautiful
letters and gifts
you have no idea how much i appreciate
it
our zip code of the day is 92806
anaheim california
[Music]
i love me from anaheim home of the
anaheim convention center that hosted
the 1985
summer olympics anaheim was orange
county's first city
and it was founded by winemakers and
grape farmers
but after the grape crops failed oranges
became the largest crop anaheim
california
also has disneyland i don't know if
you've ever heard of that
but we want to hear from you anaheim
send us some mail
all right let's get to our letter
karen anaheim california dear drew my
husband and i love your show
thank you i recently had a dream about
you
me and brooke shields going out for
donuts
do you like donuts if so what is your
favorite
uh karen who doesn't like donuts i
actually
question people who don't like donuts i
mean i'll eat a fried chew let alone a
donut
you know what's funny too is i've
actually i know
brook shields we've known each other
since we were kids
um and so i decided to actually ask her
what her favorite donut was because
well i loved your letter so
i don't know if she's showing up oh
hello
uh they didn't have my favorite donut at
the donut shop that i went to
that i go to i like to do pilates and
then i like to go get donuts
is there the i mean if there isn't
that's what they call the carrot on the
stick
that's again it's a huge donut on a
stick
um i like powdered donuts actually those
are sort of my favorite and i also like
plain
kind of boring but i really like those
but they didn't have them
today so i got us a
apple cider and a chocolate glaze
[Music]
okay that's the first time that's ever
happened on this show and i really hope
it's not the last
come on donuts are flying out from the
ceiling
oh frick this is i even have my tea
i even have a cup of tea oh i love that
that was the
um that that was the dream thank you
by the way i know i mean karen
had a dream about us eating donuts so
cheers karen here we go
karen i feel like miranda on sex in the
city she's like this
is worth it oh my god chocolate's really
good
by the way how are you i am
well done i'm very happy now because i'm
having i've got
you and a donut two things that i
love ex with my whole heart
i love you so much by the way do you
know what like sits on
um the station where i do makeup is the
book
that we did for your movie
so sweet i can't wait for that movie to
come out well it's going to be fun
they put a little thing at the end with
some outtakes of ours
which is really cute so you love
outtakes i was i'm
so excited when i saw that i was like
this is going to be great she's going to
love this
oh i can't wait to see that i couldn't
believe i got to be in your movie i was
so excited
i was so it was so much fun acting with
you we've never acted before we've just
hung out and
been people together but we've never
really uh
shared a screen so it was a special
treat for me well may it be the first of
many
including this one it's just i'm so glad
that
i've known you my whole life and i'd
never want to know life without you
oh i love you and i'm happy for all the
success
and a happy for everything and i love it
when i get to see you
hopefully i'll see you very soon another
donut break
anybody else having dreams i agree dream
about it
and write us yeah and we'll and
we'll uh we'll go through a whole
culinary um
experience i would love nothing more
thank you brooke you are the very best i
love you
[Applause]
you know you're happy when your scalp
tingles
literally you know when you smile so
hard like your occipitals burst
well anyway thank you karen for um
dreaming this up because thanks to you i
was able to reach out to brooke and make
it a reality
so thank you truly yours drew
[Music]